I guess the first film really that I was
in was called the refrigerator it was
made by some friends from college and
they had me down to the East Village I
didn't even know really what the film
was about I was in drama school at the
time but I do know that the movie was
about a refrigerator that ate people
[Music]
this is my life
[Music]
I was in Los Angeles doing a television
show I had was only two years out of
drama school and I was called over to
the Beverly Hills Hotel and I sat with
Nora and the casting director woman
named Laura Rosenthal who worked at the
time with Juliette Taylor who casts all
the Woody Allen movies and just sat and
talked with Nora and she simply said I'm
gonna put you in the movie you're gonna
play a babysitter who's a stand-up comic
and why don't we figure out what his
comedy is and he can kind of try it out
on the girls why he's while he's
babysitting them
and when I got back to New York I went
over in her apartment and the Apthorp
and I handed her these pages I really
shouldn't have done that I think she
wanted to discuss and then she was gonna
write the pages but I didn't know any
better and she looked at me somewhat
startled and said well I wasn't
expecting this and then she read them
and said you know what I think we can
work with this and suddenly I was on a
Nora Ephron set doing a scene with Julie
Kavner on subjects ichthyological I
don't mean to harp but who is grander
than the carp it's important to remember
that he's a bitter or failed comic so I
didn't need to write jokes that were
funny I was writing jokes for a bad
comic which i think is a lot easier
heavyweights I met Ben through a
classmate of mine at Juilliard and I
also knew the writer of that movie who
was a guy named Steve Brill and so I had
these two connections to Ben and kind of
like with Nora he basically said in the
room while I want you to play this part
and I didn't really think I was
appropriate for it necessarily I thought
I was a little bit young but I jumped at
the chance to do it and then I found
myself hanging out on that movie with
not only Ben but Judd Apatow
that was a really lucky early movie to
get to do and a fun supporting and not
even a supporting role but really a one
scene you know a cameo
I had a scene that involved Jerry
Stiller Ann Ann Mara Ben's parents kind
of involved them I mean I showed a
videotape with them so effectively I was
in a in a in a scene on screen with them
hi Jerry Roger Johnson Islanders fan huh
team in the future I say yeah it
astonishes me when I'm stopped and
people say oh my god heavy weights it
really does astonish me because I'm in
the movie for for just a breath The Thin
Red Line like everyone who has an
interest in movies I looked at Terry
Malick as a real hero to get the call
that I was even gonna get to read his
new script made me feel like I don't
know my time in drama school had been
worth it I went through the audition
process and I read on tape and then word
came back that Terry was interested
find something that's his make an island
for himself being around Terry was
game-changing just in terms of what I
thought was supposed to go into making a
movie and what I thought
preparation meant and was for what I
thought the relationship between the
text of a script and what actually got
shot was Terry was incredibly prepared
and he really knew his subject matter
but what we ended up shooting more very
little relation to to what the script
was and each day was largely improvised
often you would be told the day before
or on the morning of a shoot that all
your lines had been eliminated and I
think this is a part of his method of
literally visser ating all the given
circumstances of his own narrative so
that the narrative would be more
free-flowing and immediate but this was
of course hell on a lot of the actors
and particularly those of us who again
came in with certain assumptions about
well if I have this line I do get to say
it if I'm supposed to be in this scene
I'm going to show up on the day and
shoot it and just none of that ended up
being true and it humbled I think all of
us it taught me most of all that a movie
is the directors movie and we're there
to serve if you're gonna do movies you
better sign up for that and more than
sign up for it
you'd better embrace it and actually
seek out those filmmakers that you
actually don't want to end up in cookie
cutter movies that those movies end up
being the least interesting ones I was
really blessed to learn that
early on through Terry
often what he does is he shoots all day
until the last hour what's called Magic
Hour it's really about 30 minutes you
learned that that he's been shooting all
day as a kind of rehearsal to get the
scene in that 45 minute period when the
light is right well that's interesting
it's it's hard on the actors and it's
hard on the crew but you sure don't
forget it and you sure know you're gonna
end up being a part of a film that looks
like none other
oh brother where art thou o brother
where art thou I guess was was the movie
I got that changed everything I was
lucky enough to understand that as soon
as I got the script
Joel sent me the script and said can you
read this I need some advice I thought
oh he wants to talk about the adaptation
of the Odyssey because I studied
classics in college and then he offered
me del Mar I was so astounded that I
told him initially no I I'm not sure let
me spend a night thinking about it
because but I don't want to do is come
down onto a set with you and Ethan who
would become friends of mine at the time
and not come up with the goods you've
offered me this part without even
hearing me read it let me at least
assure myself that I have some purchase
on this role and he said well yeah you
can try to persuade me otherwise but we
think that that you're the right person
for the role but I spent the evening
with it and I decided all right I have a
way in here I don't even know if he
really believes that there was a
possibility I could say could have said
no but there really was because again I
didn't want to go and and be on somebody
set and have them regret having offered
me apart
[Applause]
it was all practical
there's nothing digital there I was
really chasing a toad in the water and
the toad actually did escape into the
water when I was splashing around after
it that all happened
luckily for me I was very anxious about
that scene even though it's funny and
it's extreme it's also very emotional
and there needed to be a truth in there
for it to resonate as being funny and
also dramatically compelling as funny as
that sounds the song I sing on in the
movie is in the jailhouse now and
because the movie got a Grammy for album
of the year I actually have a Grammy I
like to think of it as probably one of
the most undeserved you know I there's
no reason I should have a Grammy I got
to sing jailhouse because basically I
begged Joel to let me have a crack at it
[Music]
[Applause]
I didn't sing on constant sorrow but I
got to dance to it with Totoro and I got
to lip-synch it with Totoro
in the studio scene where we sing it and
that was just so much fun working with
John was great I used to dream fantasize
as a kid about being in a recording
studio with the headphones on there I
was in my 30s doing just what I had
fantasized about it just was a different
route and I wasn't and gonna end up
having a career in music it was just a
little moment in time that answered this
fantasy I had Minority Report but just
shot a film as a director called the
gray zone in Bulgaria I got a call from
my agent saying Steven Spielberg has
offered you a part in this new film of
his called Minority Report are you in
it's apparently a very flashy role and I
said may I read it no he's not giving
the script out you're either in or
you're out but Tim it's Steven Spielberg
you're you're gonna say yes to this and
I said I'm sorry again like I said to
Joel it's incredibly flattering but the
last thing I want to do is show up on
somebody set and not be able to come up
with the goods and and and have a
director look at me and say why did I
cast this person it's great that he
didn't want to audition me I'm not sure
why well I learned that he had seen a
brother that summer in Barry Sonnenfeld
screening room in the Hamptons and so
that's what interested him in me for
this part but I still didn't know what
the part was and so I said can I talk to
him the next day I'm in the editing room
and the assistant comes in and says
Steven Spielberg is on the phone and I
said come on I said hello it's such a
honor to meet you and he basically said
what what's the deal do you want to do
this part
what what you somebody said you needed
to talk to me and I said I just would
love to be able to read the script if
that's possible it's not because I doubt
that it's incredible it's actually the
converse of that it's it's that I doubt
that I'm gonna be good enough or
suitable anyway for the role and he said
of course you can read it that's a
perfectly legitimate thing to ask and it
was basically just a set of monologues
because the the guy talks a lot I got
all the monologues down I felt like I
really had command of them and I showed
up on set and I was called to Tom's Tom
Cruise's bus yeah this is enormous bus
it was like a shopping mall it's just
huge and so I you know wandered in and
we're working on the scene and Stephen
just doesn't seem happy at all
and I thought to myself ah it's my
nightmare is coming true I'm coming up
short I'm disappointing a director I
should have said no and he comes up and
stands next to me and he's just thinking
he's very quiet and he said can you do a
Boston accent and I gone to college in
Rhode Island that's pretty close and so
I said yes actually I can and so I did
it and he said now that's more like it
and then he started good sing with
certain sounds I was making and really
right there like a fresco painter he
just started shifting with Boston accent
as a base the way the guy spoke and
literally in that 15 minutes we came up
with who and what Gideon was and it just
suddenly felt right and everything he
was after made sense can't let you take
that out of here chief
it's against the rules anything else
called all the deal it's against rules
[Music]
careful chief you dig up the past
oh you get his dirty what's remarkable
about Steven is that he can do that with
everyone on set he just knows the entire
apparatus of filmmaking that's what's so
unbelievably special about him
Bowles I loved being in holes and the
director of that movie Andy Davis who
directed not only that movie but the
fugitive I mean talk about a wide
bandwidth was a great deal of fun and
also working with Jon Voight and
Sigourney Weaver what could have been
better it was a really fun part to play
I'm probably stopped on the street about
that movie as much as any movie in which
I've gotten to appear you might as well
teach this shovel to read
go ahead zero take it it's all you'll
ever be good for G what's that spell the
kid who hit me with the shovel in holes
is this wonderful guy who might still
know a bit named Cleo Thomas it was
great getting whacked with it with the
shovel it was a you know I again a scene
I knew was gonna be really pleasing for
the audience and I loved as an actor
taking a dive it's why a person wants to
be a character actor not being the hero
but often being the butt of jokes being
the eccentric being the dimwit being
sinister being naive all of that I mean
getting to find all those colors
roll-to-roll
is why I love acting and the kind of
acting I get to do an actor once said to
me I don't want to be the guy standing
next to the guy or opposite the guy I
want to be the guy well I want to be the
guy standing next to the guy or
opposite the guy because they often have
the best stuff to do in a movie The
Incredible Hulk that movie came at me in
a funny way because I was about to
direct this film I'd written called
leaves of grass with Edward Norton and
he and I were producing it together as
well and I got called down I think the
Mercer hotel the lobby of the Mercer
hotel to meet Louis Leterrier the
director of Incredible Hulk and Galen
heard his producer and they said we want
you to play this scientist character and
I'd read the script he was a wildly
eccentric guy mainly in the second half
of the movie and I thought all right
that's that's interesting to me I've
been in one of these movies before and
then they said well you're gonna become
the villain in the next movie so you'll
basically be signing up for three movies
and you're gonna be this character
called the leader and I thought oh my
god this is fantastic I said well who
who else have you cast and they said
well weirdly you're our first offer
which was I thought was strange because
nobody was gonna come see the movie
because I was playing this scientist or
even because I was gonna be the villain
they needed a guy to play banner and I
said who's and they said well it's
either gonna be Mark Ruffalo or Edward
Norton and I think I even said but wait
a minute
Edward and you know Edwards supposed to
do my movie and and I'm no contest for
you guys of course he's gonna want to
play banner and I called Edward and he
said basically Tim get real of course
I'm gonna play Bruce Banner that's gonna
be fantastic you're possibly gonna be in
the movie with me it'll be a blast and
then we'll do your movie I'm not going
anywhere and Edwards a man of his word
and so we got to act I got to act in a
movie with Edward right before directing
him for both of us we did Hulk and then
leaves of grass was our next movie
I take your hands off
I learned so much about shooting from
Louis Leterrier as I often do because I
direct my little movies I hang around on
sets even when I'm not needed and just
watch what the director is up to because
all these guys with whom I get to work
know so much more about it than I do
Lincoln this time when when I got the
call I didn't risk offending Stephen I
said yes without reading the script it
helped to know that Tony Kushner had
written the script but III just said
fine I'm not gonna hassle him again I'm
in and the real fun for that movie for
me was the set environment because
Daniel day-lewis stays in character
always but in addition to that he
demands that there be no anachronism
'he's on set nothing that wouldn't blend
in at least to the period was allowed on
set that just furnished a level of
decorum and seriousness and focus the
likes of which i've seen on no other set
and then there was just having a scene
opposite daniel it felt to me like I was
a decent enough painter in 1925 who got
to go into Picasso's studio and watch
him work and just completely transform
and reorganize an entire approach to the
art form it just he's working on such a
level where the transformation of the
man was just molecular I literally
couldn't find him in there all I saw was
Lincoln the Democrats we've yet to bag
sir the patronage job simply won't bag
him they require more convincing mr.
president
mm that I got to be in two of Stephens
movies has been incredibly meaningful to
me because he likes to change it up he
can have any pigment he wants for his
canvas he'll only use the ones because
he can that are exactly right for what
he wants and I'm lucky that my my color
was right for two of the movies The
Ballad of Buster Scruggs Joel gave me
that script after a brother had been
released and because I had done my own
my own singing for in the jailhouse now
he and Ethan decided that I should play
a singing cowboy and that would be
really funny and sort of contrapuntal
because I'm not what you'd really think
of as a cowboy type they find that funny
and so they they said well let's have
him do this and and do pistol tricks and
we'll write a short and it'll be
companioned with these other shorts so
18 years later they came to me and said
alright we're ready to make it they got
it financed and they took me to dinner
and said alright you're gonna need to be
able to sing four songs we need you to
play the guitar and we need you to do
all these pistol tricks you've got six
months I had a great six months working
on that every day my son taught me to
play the guitar and I loved the
character so much I just wasn't gonna
let him down
[Music]
today because I felt that I'd really
prepared and I was ready we had a
wonderful time shooting it's one of the
best times I've ever had on a movie and
I've had a lot of fun on movie sets but
I don't think I've had more fun than on
the Buster Scruggs set Watchmen what I
love about Watchmen is that while it's
based on a graphic novel slash comic and
it has superhero elements particularly
with dr. Manhattan really Watchmen is
about vigilantism it's about justice
it's about human frailty called revenge
and how that's misinterpreted as a
strength and I think what Damon in
particular is examining in the show
Watchmen is what revenge can allow for
not just in the vengeful person but in
the tit-for-tat in response to revenge
and how revenge and vigilantism build on
themselves and then finally what it
brings out in someone to wear a mask why
would they start this [ __ ] up again
maybe there was something wrong pal
Damon and the writers have written a
character for me who's got some very
complicated issues and he allowed for
those issues to be explored both when
they're directly being explored and they
are over the course of the season but
also just in his behavior when they
aren't being explored and you can infer
a kind of fragility and despair in the
guy and I get to be a scene partner with
Regina King truly one of the classiest
people I've met doing what I do
Jeremy Irons Don Johnson the legend I'm
very excited about the show I think it's
wildly inventive I think people are
gonna be surprised
moved and very engaged just mercy just
mercy is exactly the kind of film in
which I'd like to appear it's made by
destined Daniel [ __ ] first of all who
has proven himself to be one of the
talented and innovative directors around
if you watch just mercy just think about
where there could be score under some of
the performances and he doesn't furnish
it and he allows the actors the writing
and the simplicity of the photography to
tell the story Jamie Foxx plays Walter
McMillian and Michael B Jordan who also
produced the movie plays Bryan Stevenson
and I got to work with both those guys
in those wounds you're gonna be making a
lot of people very unhappy
when people care about a thing that much
do anything to get what they want the
character I play is also the victim of
an extremely difficult life coming up
through foster care he was nearly burned
alive and where's those scars literally
on his face
and who was basically frightened by the
DEA and the Sheriff's Department in
Monroe County Alabama to put this guy on
help put this guy on death row and he
has to come to terms with that the
report the report is a movie made by
Scott Z burns who's a protege of Steven
Soderbergh I originally met Scott
because he wrote this wonderful play
called the library about the Columbine
shootings that Steven Soderbergh ended
up directing at the public Scott thought
of me for the report gave me this
wonderful role I guess of a character
you'd call a whistleblower but you know
my presence in that movie is really as a
part of a greater ensemble of some other
really wonderful New York actors many of
them stage actors that were put in the
film by Scott and the wonderful casting
director AV Kaufman you know you've got
Maura tyranny and Jon Hamm Linda Powell
Annette Bening playing Dianne Feinstein
and so it's just scene after scene of I
think selfless performers if such a
combination of words as possible in the
vicinity of the word truth we watch the
video
I think you know as an actor in in roles
like that it's always important to know
where you fit
what's the spine which is usually best
told in terms of the protagonist and in
the case of the rapport it's the amazing
Adam driver the job of the actor I
believe anyway or my job in those sorts
of films is just how I help drive his or
her story forward and to fit in in the
right way in playing the truth of the
scenes don't do too much so that you get
in the way it's the other person's story
it's not a movie about you